Кількість автомобілів у світі щороку дедалі зростає.
За даними Greenpeace, автопромисловість відповідальна
за майже 9 відсотків глобальних викидів CO2. Чи можна зменшити
ці викиди, віддаючи перевагу, приміром, електромобілям?
Автоконцерни, які десятиліттями нехтували розвитком
електромобільності, тепер просувають їх як
чи не єдине вирішення всіх проблем.
Завдяки державним дотаціям у Німеччині у червні цього року
було зареєстровано понад вісім тисяч нових електрокарів.
Це на 41% більше порівняно з червнем минулого року.
Однак у червні також зареєстрували близько 212 тисяч нових машин
із двигунами внутрішнього згоряння. Це майже у 30 разів більше,
ніж електрокарів, тож шлях до електричного майбутнього
виглядає усе ще дуже далеким. Замало моделей, вони занадто
дорогі, виробництво акумуляторів екологічно шкідливе
і нерозвинена мережа станцій підзарядок у порівнянні з
класичною мережею АЗС. Усе це гальмує розвиток електромобільності.
До того ж, що робити з традиційними автомобілями,
яких один мільярд 200 мільйонів в усьому світі? Майже всі вони -
з двигунами внутрішнього згоряння і викидають надто багато
шкідливих речовин у довкілля.
А ще є кілька сотень мільйонів мопедів і мотоциклів,
які також працюють на традиційному "брудному" паливі.
Як зробити їх "чистими"?
Одна з можливих відповідей - альтернативне пальне.
Німецька залізниця Deutsche Bahn оголосила, що використовуватиме
більше альтернативних видів пального у своїх дизельних двигунах.
А німецький автовиробник Porsche вирішив розпочати власні
дослідження альтернативних видів пального. Адже легендарна модель
911 і надалі мусить мати фантастичний шестициліндровий
двигун позаду.
Альтернативне пальне - це біопаливо, яке можна
використовувати вже. Однак у глобальному масштабі
його недостатньо. Це могло би бути принаймні однією складовою.
Але біопаливо, виготовлене з кукурудзи, ріпаку чи пальмової олії,
вимагає вирощення величезної кількості монокультур
у сільському господарстві, що теж шкодить довкіллю. З цієї причини
синтетичне паливо, так зване електронне, нині базується
на діоксиді вуглецю та водню.
Для виробництва водню потрібна електроенергія, в ідеалі,
звісно, "зелена" електроенергія. Наприклад, енергія вітру.
Вітряний день на німецькому узбережжі Північного моря.
Ідеально підходить для кайт-серфінгістів та вітряних турбін.
Вони виробляють багато електроенергії - іноді більше,
ніж потрібно. Цей надлишок можна використати
для виробництва водню.
Наприклад, Audi у своєму пілотному проєкті на півночі Німеччини
виробляє водень, використовуючи зелену електроенергію за допомогою
електролізу. На другому етапі він реагує з вуглекислим газом,
утворюючи метан. Він подається у загальну мережу природного газу.
Необхідний діоксид вуглецю виробляється у вигляді промислових
відходів або із сільськогосподарських відходів.
Однак коефіцієнт корисної дії такого пального вкрай низький. Наприклад,
в автомобілів на природному газі в рушійну силу перетворюється лише
10-15% використаної енергії, в електродвигунах - до 70%.
Природний газ можна використовувати різними способами.
Наприклад, у двигунах внутрішнього згоряння, як у цій Seat Arona TGi.
До речі, це досить стара ідея: перша заправка для природного газу
в Німеччині була ще в 1935 році. А Італія та Нідерланди розпочали
розбудову своєї загальнонаціональної мережі
газових заправок ще у 70-х роках.
Цей невеликий позашляховик, як стверджує репортер DW, вже подолав
близько 12 тисяч кілометрів. І жодних проблем не виникало.
Під час руху різницяз бензиновим двигуном не відчувається. Завдяки
своєму трициліндровому двигуну об’ємом один літр і потужністю
90 кінських сил Seat Arona достатньо спритна. І при середньому
споживанні чотирьох кіло газу на сотню кілометрів цілком екологічна.
Але залишається один недолік: газові баки дуже громіздкі.
Однак ще більше дратує обмежений запас ходу, коли їдеш на газі.
Одного бака пального вистачає приблизно на 250 кілометрів,
додаткового 9-літрового бензинового бака - ще на 100 кілометрів,
тож необхідно ретельно планувати довгі маршрути.
Мережу газових заправок ще є куди розвивати. Станом на 2019 рік
Німеччині 850 станцій - цього в принципі достатньо
для повсякденного життя. В Італії їх навіть 1250.
Але в інших країнах ситуація значно гірша: якщо подорожуєте до Франції,
там лише 74 станції, а в Іспанії - взагалі лише 58. Це проблема, яка
стосується не лише газових, але й водневих заправок.
Нині є дві тенденції щодо транспорту з нейтральним викидом CO2.
Основна увага надається автомобілям з акумуляторними
батареями, оскільки ця технологія на кілька років випереджає другу
альтернативу - водень. Деякі автовиробники розробляють водневі
моделі доволі швидко, і перші машини вже з'явилися в Європі.
Тим не менше головний акцент у водневих розробках нині задають
деінде, приміром, у Каліфорнії.
Mercedes представив свої перші прототипи на водні ще в 90-х роках.
Тоді привід на паливних елементах займав весь багажник.
А от першим у світі серійним водневим автомобілем стала
Toyota Mirai наприкінці 2014-го. Однак це все ще нішевий продукт,
так би мовити, для "технічних ботаніків": торіку світі продали лише
10 тисяч таких авто.
Ян Брабанд, засновник медичного стартапу в Гамбурзі,
який за допомогою інноваційних технологій працює над поліпшенням
засвоєння харчових добавок, вірить у майбутнє з воднем.
Ми хотіли автомобіль, який би був більш екологічним у дорозі.
Воднева технологія переконала мене від самого початку. Працює
абсолютно бездоганно. Хоча для мене трохи дивно: на відміну від
бензинового двигуна, запас ходу в місті більший, ніж на автобані.
500 кілометрів по місту - не проблема.
Але в Німеччині не налічується й сотні водневих заправних станцій.
Змагання між різними видами палива визначається також
економічним зиском: чиї мільйонні інвестиції зрештою окупляться,
а хто потрапить під колеса?
Водень може бути альтернативою для транспорту, але лише там, де в нас
немає електричної альтернативи. Тобто для суден, літаків та
міжміських вантажних перевезень. Водень повинен вироблятися
з відновлюваних джерел енергії - з енергії вітру і сонця, а не з вугілля,
атомної енергії чи природного газу.
Отже, досягти кліматичних цілей можна лише завдяки поєднанню
різних технологій: нові види синтетичного пального можуть
зробити мільйони двигунів внутрішнього згоряння
більш екологічними. А на наступному етапі буде вже
електрична мобільність - як місток до епохи водню без СО2.